speaking of bad timing I want to talk to
you about the conspiracy trial that was
up going against Ammon Bundy and his six
co-defendants from this armed militia
you might remember that uh Ammon Bundy
and six co-defendants were charged with
conspiring to impede federal employees
at the Malheur National Wildlife Refuge
through intimidation threat or force
stemming from a 41 day occupation of
that Wildlife Refuge and they were
charged with possessing guns in a
federal facility illegally two of the
defendants were facing an additional
charge of theft of government property
all defendants have been found not
guilty period and even worse is that
there are local sheriff's and individual
elected officials who believe this was
the correct decision they like this type
of dangerous hillbilly activism as i
like to call it and what has become very
clear through this verdict is that we
have to justice systems in this country
there is one for uh i mean you could
actually slice and dice it however you
want there's one for those protesting
big government in order to defend the
constitution in some amorphous way and
there is another justice system for
those who are protesting for example and
oil fracking pipeline in the Dakotas
through their territory and I will get
to that a little bit later and you could
also make a racial argument right which
is wait a second David you've got the
six or seven I'm armed white defendants
occupying federal land illegally with
firearms and not only are they not taken
out or subdued by federal authorities
they eventually are taken to court and
found not guilty if they were Muslim or
if they were black do you believe that
that they would have been allowed to
occupy this armed up for 41 days I don't
not at all I mean these people were able
to rip off the federal government for
years on end and then occupied a federal
building for 41 days and there was no
sense of urgency whatsoever they were
threatening any authorities that were
going to come after I'm right I mean if
if this was at black lives matter
if this was a Muslim group they would
have been out in days yet maybe a day
but but at the most days now at the same
time in North Dakota we have
heavily-armed riot police using pepper
spray bean bags which are similar to
rubber bullets sirens on Native
Americans protesting the construction of
an oil pipeline on land that they say is
theirs by right of treaty mind you not
some vague assertions about the
Constitution in states rights as we saw
with the armed Oregon militia let's put
it a different way just to really
contextualize this you have armed
out-of-state occupiers led by Ammon
Bundy who break into a bird sanctuary
and seize control of a federal
government building for 41 days it leads
to school closures it requires extra
security in the area mental health
counselors they were heavily armed and
holding target practice during the
standoff all acquitted in North Dakota
native american tribes are protesting an
upstream oil pipeline that would move
half a million uh barrels of fracked oil
per day through their area they've been
protesting by camping out mostly
peaceful there have been some occasional
clashes with security security comes in
they were filmed using dogs and pepper
spray on protesters ultimately the
National Guard came in heavily armed
police in riot gear and authorities
report that a hundred and forty-one
people were arrested on top of the
nearly 200 that it were arrested earlier
on in the protest corporate media
ignoring this story versus the Oregon
nutjobs where you bring on right-wingers
to corporate media to say oh well you
know here's why they're actually
warranted in what they're doing the
Constitution states rights that the does
the Bureau of Land Management really
have any authority anyway America where
justice is made up and the right thing
doesn't really matter but it makes a
sort of sixth sense if you think about
it doesn't it because the Dakota
protests are over an oil pipeline we've
gone to war for cheap energy in the
country so it probably isn't that
surprising when you think about it Pat
that the violence against the protesters
is happening not when they are white and
armed but when they are protesting
something related to oil and there's
also an angle of these are white
right-wingers versus Native American
left-wingers presumably and you know we
have a system what child trial by jury
in this country and a lot of times that
isn't perfect but you would imagine that
a mostly white jury wouldn't when
convict these people taking over federal
land and what's the effect of this going
to be this is going to embolden other
armed militants who would love to be
confronting whatever government
authority they don't agree with with but
by the ways most of them they are going
to see this and they will be encouraged
the extremist Patriot types that
organizations like the anti-defamation
league and so many others track they are
going to see this verdict and they're
going to say look at this look at what
they were able to do yeah that one guy
died he was shot dead by the FBI which
we covered but by and large everybody
who is charged was acquitted this is now
legitimizing and encouraging people to
take more of these actions it is
incredibly dangerous we're going to
continue covering it but if you've ever
seen uh a more blatant exposition of the
to justice systems that we have in this
country it applies in many ways the rich
and the not rich it goes along racial
lines it can go along what your impetus
for protesting is there's so many ways
in which we have to justice systems in
this country it has not been more clear
than this for many many years the
election is just a few days away and if
you're feeling that confident and if you
look at my email you'll see that a lot
of people are feeling very confident
about what's going to happen on november
eighth you can actually put your money
where your mouth is with that d si.com
if you're so confident that you know
what will happen you can actually make
money off of that you can pick your
candidates at bet d si.com and like in
the real world the odds are still with
hillary clinton at bet the si.com but
they've tightened slightly in favor of
Donald Trump and you can have some fun
give it a try and you can get a free $25
election play using promo code Pakman 25
that's PA ke ma and 25 bet dsi has been
in business for over 20 years and they
have markets where you can bet on pretty
much everything and my interest is in
elections and the mobile site actually
works well it's not like some of those
websites where you access the website
from your phone and it's just a total
disaster you can play hundreds of
different markets the election with
Trump versus Hillary Clinton state by
state election odds and of course a
whole bunch of other stuff and again if
you really sure that you're that great
of a predictor as to who's going to win
the upcoming election you can go to bed
d si.com and use pakman 25 as your
signup code to get 25 bucks